I want to begin in Volume 13, and this is May the first 1921.
The human will casts dissimilarity between the creator and the creature.
For one who lives in the divine will, everything is harmony.
So, Luisa said, "Continue in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself in the
midst of a multitude of people." And Op High, there was the Queen Mother.
Now, Op High always means living in the divine will, living the great eagle on the
mountain. And she was speaking to that people, and she was crying so much, in fact,
that holding a bunch of roses on her lap, she wet them with her tears.
I could not understand anything of what she was saying.
I could only see that the people wanted to make two molds, and that the celestial
mother was praying them, crying to calm down.
And then she detached one rose, and pointing to me, in the midst of so many
people, she threw it to me. I looked at it.
The rose was paralleled with the tears of my dear mother, and those tears
invited me to pray for the peace of these peoples.
Now, here we see a lovely image of Mary as the mother of all people.
She was constituted mother at the foot of the cross, and here she is interceding
for her children, wanting to bring them to peace and to harmony with God.
Then afterwards, I found myself together with my sweet Jesus, and I prayed him
for the peace of the peoples, and he, drawing me to myself, spoke to me about
his most holy will. Now, in the middle of all this intercession, our lady
pointed Louisa out as the one to intercede, because Louisa was the victim
soul, and she was also called to open up the kingdom of the divine will.
So naturally, she was the one that was pointed to.
So Jesus explains the mission given to Louisa and through her to the rest of us.
"My daughter," he said, "my will contains the creative power."
Now, he keeps saying this, and we need to take it on board, that when we enter
into the divine will and make the divine will our own, we have that creative power
in our hands. And this creative power is what originated the universe.
It's the source of the three fiats.
"My will," he said, "contains the creative power.
And just as my will gave life to all things."
So you have Genesis 1 and 2. You have Colossians 1, 16.
You have Ephesians 1, 10.
It gave life to everything.
Of course, also, you have John chapter 1, verses 1 to 5.
It gave life to all things, so it gave physical life.
It gave spiritual life, because the divine will is the source of all life.
Of course, you have John 14, 6 as well.
"I am the way, the truth, and the life."
So, "my will" contains the creative power.
And just as my will gave life to all things, so it has the power to destroy them.
So for this, I want to give you Jeremiah chapter 1, verses 9 to 10,
where Jeremiah was told that he was called to build up and plant and to build up
and to break down and destroy as well.
Now, the soul who lives in my volition also has the power to give life,
life to that which is good, and to give debt to that which is evil,
to plant, to build up, to break down and destroy.
So, I also want to give you Jeremiah chapter 10, verses 6 to 15,
and verses 23 to 24.
So, let's read that again. It's actually very important.
The soul who lives in my volition also has the power to give life to good
and to give death to evil.
So, the very fact of being in the divine will means that we are very much
participators in this spiritual warfare that is going on continuously.
It has just come to mind, the same Paul said,
"The weapons of our warfare are not carnal,
but they are mighty in pulling down the strongholds of evil."
And that's what is referred to here, to give death to evil.
In the immensity of the divine will, the soul finds herself in the past,
and wherever there are voids to my glory, or fences to be repaired,
love not given to me, she fills the voids of my glory.
She makes for me the most beautiful reparations,
and she gives me love for everybody.
In my will, she diffuses herself in the present.
She extends to the future centuries, and everywhere, and for everyone,
she gives me that which creation owes me.
So, you see that the mission we have is very great and very extensive.
It covers the past, the present, and the future.
All souls from Adam to Zachary, A to Z.
In the soul who lives in my will, I hear the echo of my power,
of my love, and of my sanctity.
In all my acts, I hear the echo of hers.
She runs everywhere before me, behind me, and even inside of me.
Wherever my will is, there is hers.
As my acts multiply themselves, hers also multiply.
Only the human will puts disharmony between the creator and the creature.
One single act of the human will puts chaos between heaven and earth.
Chaos is a big word now,
because it means disharmony disintegration, things falling apart.
One single act of the human will puts chaos between heaven and earth,
and it casts dissimilarity between the creator and the creature.
On the other hand, for one who lives in my will, everything is harmony.
Her things and mine harmonize together.
I am with her on earth, and she is with me in heaven.
We have the same interest, the same life, and there's only one will between us.
This really doesn't require a comment.
It does require a lot of meditation and thinking and praying.
To live in the divine will is to have one will and one life.
You're living on earth and you're also living in heaven.
And the divine will is living in heaven and also living on earth.
So I want to give you John 14-21.
You and me and I in you, both completely one.
See, because creation has not moved from my will in anything,
because creation wasn't given any free will.
So it moves only in the will of God.
The sky is always Asia blue.
It's always starry.
The sun is always full of light and heat.
The whole of creation is in perfect harmony.
One thing is the support of the other.
There's no individual will in battle against any other will.
So everything is in harmony.
Everything supports one another.
So it's always beautiful.
It's always fresh and it's always young.
It never grows old.
Nor does it lose one shadow of its beauty.
On the contrary, it seems that each day the divine will rises as more majestic,
giving a sweet enchantment to all creatures.
So would man have been if he had not withdrawn from my will?
And so are the souls who actually do live in my will.
So let me look at what he has just said.
So are the souls who live in my will.
They are always beautiful, always fresh, always young.
They never grow old.
They don't lose their beauty.
On the contrary, each day the divine will grows more beautiful in them.
It's wonderful.
They are the new heavens, the new suns and the new earth,
the all flowery, even more varied with beauty and enchantment.
This is the new Jerusalem which you will find described in John 21, sorry, not John.
This is the new Jerusalem described in the book of Revelation, chapter 21 and 22.
So may the 21st 1921.
Jesus finds rest in the souls who live in his will.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "My beloved Jesus made himself seen in my arms
in the act of taking rest.
I clashed into my heart, saying to him, 'My love, say a word to me, why are you silent?'
It has occurred to me to say a word about what Louisa means by her usual state.
Louisa's usual state is a state of ecstasy.
She sits there in the bed, hour upon hour upon hour in communion with God.
Sometimes she has an out of the body experience.
Sometimes she doesn't.
Visions and revelations are perfectly normal for her.
So normal in fact that she complains if she doesn't have it.
So now she wants a revelation.
That's the meaning of a word, a davar in Hebrew.
On Mount Sinai, God gave ten words to the people,
which we unfortunately call ten commandments as if he was thundering from on high.
He gave ten words, ten revelations to show us how weak and broken, and in that case
unredeemed human beings could actually live together in harmony.
So Jesus continues, 'My beloved daughter, rest is necessary to me.
And having spoken to you so much, I want in you the first effects of my words.
So you must work doing what I have taught you, and I will rest.'
This is the pattern you find in the Bible.
In Genesis chapter 1, God did the work of creation, and then he rested.
In the gospel of Saint John, you have Jesus doing the work of redemption,
and then he rests on the Sabbath day before the resurrection.
And I deliberately say John's gospel because John brings it out much more than the other three gospels do.
And so what Jesus is saying is that in us, when he reveals something to us in the divine will,
he's doing the work of revealing.
But then we must do the work of putting it into practice.
And as we put it into practice, that gives him rest, and then he will go to work again.
But of course, before he actually gives us the revelation, he has to work in us to dispose us, to receive it.
He has to prepare our souls so that we're actually able to accept the revelation.
Very often he has to expand our soul in order that there is enough space in us for this new revelation that he's going to make.
So let me repeat that again.
My beloved daughter rest is necessary to me.
After having spoken to you so much, I want in you the first effects of my words.
So you must work doing what I have taught you and I will rest.
And when you have put my teachings into execution, that means you actually put them into practice.
I will come back again to speak to you of higher and more sublime things.
So we don't deserve the higher and more sublime things if we haven't put the lower things into practice.
If you put that in a different way, you don't put the roof on the house until you put the foundations in and you built up the walls.
Otherwise, it would be monumentally stupid.
So I want to give you James, chapter 1, verses 22 to 25, where he says that you must not just listen to the word, you must also put it into practice.
So Jesus will come back and tell us higher and more sublime things if we have put the lower foundational things into practice.
I will come back again, he said, to speak to you of higher and more sublime things, to be able to find rest more beautiful in you.
And besides, if I do not rest in the souls who live in my will, in whom could I hope to rest?
Because if the others are not even listening to him, let alone putting something into practice.
Only the souls who live in my will are capable of giving me rest.
Now we're going to see that this rest is union with God.
The living in my will forms the room or the space or the tabernacle for Jesus.
The act on in my will form for me the bed or the resting place.
The repeated acts, the constancy in repeating are the lullabies, so the constancy in repeating our acts are the lullabies, the music and the opium to favor my sleep.
Now you'll notice that this is 1921, and at that particular stage, opium had been discovered as something that really can not only put you to sleep, but can actually go much deeper and make a drug addict out of you and cause all kinds of hallucinations and everything.
But at that particular stage, they didn't know the negative side of opium. They didn't realize that opium had to be taken in very small doses if you were to benefit from it.
And so the thing that fascinates me is that whatever has been discovered on earth, Jesus will mention it. He'll mention electricity and all the rest of it.
"But while I sleep," he said, "I watch over you in such a way that your will is nothing other than the outpouring of mine. Your thoughts, the outpouring of my intelligence, your word, the outpouring of mine, your heart, the outpouring of mine."
So even though you don't hear me speak, there is such dissolving of yourself in me. That's your John 14, 21, and also Galatians 2, 20, "I no longer live, Christ lives in me."
So even though you don't hear me speak, there is such dissolving of yourself in me that you do not want or think or do anything but what I myself want and do.
So as long as you live in my will, you can be sure that everything that goes on within you is me. There is a description of union with God.
And this is the glory of our lives. And this is what we're called to.
You go back to the beginning of this, and he said, "He has to dispose us to be able to receive what he's giving us."
So he gives us his revelation and his word. We take it on board. We put it into practice. We start living this.
And as we start living this, he is able to make room for himself. He's able to make a new tabernacle on earth.
So for that room or that tabernacle, I want to give you one Corinthians 3, 16.
And he's able to make this space or this tabernacle for himself.
And then the acts on in his will form the place where he can rest the manger, if you like. He says, "Bed here."
And the repeated act and the constancy in repeating that we don't give up are the lullabies and the music and the opium to favour sleep.
Now notice that Jesus mentions lullabies, music and opium to help sleep.
He's talking about people having trouble to sleep. They're not lying down in bed and just knocking over into an absolutely restful sleep.
He's talking about people who need help to get into that sleep mode.
And we know that children love stories and that babies love lullabies.
And that infants absolutely love really good music.
I remember watching a child who was only a couple of months old on the floor listening to Mozart and absolutely loving it.
They loved the harmony.
But if you gave the same child some of the modern music with all its frenetic, hellish beat, the child would cry.
It was the harmony that was touching the harmony that was in the child.
And so in order to favour sleep, we need that peace, we need that harmony.
And so he's touching on the fact that we need to come into harmony with him.
And that as we come into harmony with him, it's like him receiving lullabies.
And when our will comes into harmony with his, it's like him having that taste of opium that sends him into a very quiet, deep sleep.
But he's not sleeping like we do, not at all.
When Jesus was on earth in the incarnation, as he slept at night.
I don't know if he slept the whole night, every night, I doubt it.
But as he slept, he was also God governing the universe,
bringing children to birth and taking people in death.
He was also being the sovereign Lord of the universe.
And so he's saying here that while our acts enable him to rest and to sleep in us, at the same time,
while this is happening, he said, "While I sleep, I watch over you in such a way that your will is nothing other but the outpouring of mine."
That means that as we surrender to him, we allow his will to operate through us.
This is what is required.
It allows his intelligence to come through our thoughts.
That's exactly the transformation we need.
It allows his word to have an outpouring through ours, and it allows his love to have an outpouring through our hearts.
This is the transformation.
This is our transfiguration.
So even though he said you don't hear me speak, there is such a dissolving of yourself in me that you don't want, think, or do anything that I myself don't want or do.
So let's go on to June the 2nd, 1921.
In coming upon the earth, Jesus said almost nothing or very little about his will.
The reason for that, of course, is that he has to accomplish redemption first, and then put in the divine will foundations, and then when humanity and the church had matured sufficiently that we could receive the rest.
That's like saying you bring a child into the world, and you might have wonderful plans for that child to become a professional and all the rest of it, but you've got to wait some time.
Because the child has got to go through all its baby stages, its toddler stages, its primary school, its secondary school, its university, before they can actually be the one that you are dreaming about right now.
So Louisa said I was feeling very oppressed because they told me that they wanted to print everything that my sweet Jesus had manifested to me about his most holy will.
And my anguish is so great that I felt also agitated.
Jesus doesn't like the agitation, you see, and my sweet Jesus in my interior means that the kingdom of God is actually present there. So that's Luke 17, 21, and 1 Corinthians 3, 16, the kingdom of God is already there.
So he speaks to her in her interior. Do you want to arbitrate yourself? He said that's nice.
Only because a teacher wanted to dictate a doctrine of his to one pupil, the doctrine can be made public, or the good that can be done with it, this would be absurd, and with Sandman's teacher, and besides of you, there is nothing, it's all my doctrine.
John 15, 5, without me, you can do nothing.
You've been nothing other than a clerk.
And only because I have chosen you, you would want to bury my teachings, and therefore also my glory.
Matthew 5, 14 to 15, you do not put a lamp under a lampstand. You put it on the lampstand so that everybody will see, and that everybody can benefit from the light.
It's crazy to put on a light and hide it.
And so what you have here is that Louisa cannot see what's happening to her objectively, now most of us don't.
And this is the very reason why you need spiritual direction and so on.
And so the Lord is saying to her, you actually have no idea what my plans are. She didn't know.
Even though he has begun to unfold it piece by piece, she still doesn't get it. She doesn't get the big picture.
And because she doesn't get the big picture, she's only looking at it from her own perspective.
A woman sitting in a bed, hidden away from the world, having a private experience of God, and somebody wants to publish these intimacies.
As far as she's concerned, it's horrendous.
But she doesn't know what the Lord is revealing.
And so he has to plead with her many times to let him have his way.
But with all this, she said, I felt restless.
And my beloved Jesus coming out from within my interior, surrounded my neck with his arm.
And clasping me tightly, he said, my beloved daughter, would you cam yourself, cam yourself, and make me happy.
Now, many times you get this description that Jesus will come out from her interior and put his arms around her neck.
That is actually straight from the Song of Songs, chapter 2, verse 6.
His left hand is under my arm and his right arm embraces me.
So the image there is of the bride and the bridegroom.
And you see that this relationship is that of the bride and the bridegroom.
So Louisa said, my love, the sacrifice is too hard.
At the mere thought that everything that has passed between you and me has to come out,
I feel myself dying and my heart breaks with the pain.
If I wrote, it was only to obey and for fear that you might be displeased.
And now look at what amaze obedience is casting me into.
My life have pity on me, she said, put your holy hand into this.
In other words, she says, would you take over and control this whole business?
And he said to her, but what if I wanted the sacrifice?
You must be ready to make it, he said, and you must not deny me anything.
Now that was the testimony of Padre Pio. When he was asked why God was able to work so many
miracles through him for so long, his answer was very simple.
He said, I refuse him nothing and he refuses me nothing.
It's an enormous harmony that's there between God's will and ours.
And so Jesus said to her, and if I wanted this sacrifice, you'd have to be able to give it.
Because after all, you've handed your will over to me, haven't you?
Now you must know that in coming upon the earth, I came to manifest my celestial doctrine,
to make known my humanity, my fatherland, and the order that the creature was to have in order to reach heaven.
That's the whole plan of salvation. In a word you call it the gospel.
But of my will, I said almost nothing or very little.
I almost passed over it because it wasn't the time.
The infant was still in the womb. Jesus had to bring the church into being.
The church didn't have its birthday until Pentecost, when Jesus was already dead and risen and ascended.
He'd already gone back to the Father. So things have to take time.
And there are certain things can only happen at certain points.
You can't teach a child in the cradle about trigonometry.
It's just not the time. You've got to wait about 15 years or 14 anyway.
So at the time of the gospel, he said, "Of my will, I said almost nothing or very little."
I almost passed over it, making them understand that the thing about which I cared the most was the will of my father.
Now that's all over John's gospel.
I only do what my father tells me to do. I only say what my father tells me to say.
I only reveal what my father tells me to reveal. I and the Father are one.
And then all his wonderful attestations of obedience to the Father come to a head in John 1431,
where he says, "I want the world to know that I love the Father, and therefore I do exactly what my Father tells me."
So he said, "I only told them that I cared the most about the will of my father.
But of the qualities of the divine will, of its magnificence, its greatness, the height of its sanctity and glory and power,
of the great goods that the creature would receive in living in my divine will, I said almost nothing."
And this was because the creature being too much of an infant in celestial things would have understood nothing.
So there's your baby and your trigonometry.
It was too soon.
I only taught the Church to pray, "Fiat Volontas Tuha, see good in Chelo at in Terra.
Thy will be done on earth as in heaven."
So that she might dispose herself to know this will of mine in order to love it and to do it.
I want to give you Hebrews 5, 11 to 14.
That's where the author of the Hebrews says it's time to grow up.
So as the Church was growing up and maturing, every single day of her life she has repeated over and over and over again the Our Father prayer.
So this was to help the Church to dispose herself to know this will of God in order to love it and to do it and therefore receive the gifts it contains.
Now, what I was to do at that time, the teachings about my will, which I was to give to all, he said, "I've given to you."
So the Church hadn't reached the spiritual maturity required and hadn't prayed the Our Father sufficiently until 2000 years later.
In other words, that entire bank of prayer and all the suffering and struggle and sacrifices of the Church were all needed to open the revelation about the divine will.
So making them known is nothing other than making up for what I myself was to do while on earth as the fulfillment of my coming.
Don't you want me then to fulfill the purpose of my coming on earth?
Therefore, let me do. He pleads with Louise a time out of number to let him do. I wonder how often he has to plead with us to let him do.
I will watch over everything and I will dispose everything you only have to follow me and be at peace.
So there I want to give you Psalm 90 verse 3.
So, June the 6th, 1921, the greatest miracle that God can perform is for a soul to live in the Fiat.
Now, I want you to put a VIP on this. This is extremely important.
Louise said, "I was dissolving myself in the holy will of blessed Jesus and I thought to myself, which one is greater, more varied, more complex, the work of creation or the redeeming work?"
And Jesus said, "My daughter, the redeeming work is greater, more varied and complex than the work of creation.
Even more, it is so much greater that each act of the redeeming work is immense seas that surround the work of creation.
And the work of creation surrounded by the redeeming work remains as nothing other than little rivulets surrounded by the immense, immensely vast seas of the redeeming work."
Now, the one who lives in my will, who takes my Fiat Volantis to her as her life, flows within these immense seas of the redeeming work.
She diffuses and expands together with them in such a way as to surpass the very work of creation.
Again, it's not commentary you need, it's meditation.
And it's asking the Lord to open our intellects and open our wills, open our reason, open our hearts so that we can really receive this.
Therefore, only the life of my Fiat can give true honor and glory to the work of creation.
Only the life of my Fiat, because my Fiat multiplies and extends everywhere it has no limits.
On the other hand, the work of creation has its limits, nor can it become larger than it actually is.
Jesus continues, "My daughter, the greatest miracle that my omnipotence can perform is for a soul to live in my Fiat."
Let us all say to him, "Would great fervor, Lord, let your Fiat live in me, and Lord, let me live in your Fiat."
Do you think it's trivial that my will wholly immense eternal could descend into a creature and putting my will and hers together?
This creature, even in the littlest things he thinks as trivial, says the greatest miracle that could possibly happen. It means total surrender on our part.
He lives. He is. We're not running our intellects. He is. We're not running our hearts. He is. He's running everything. He's Lord.
We used to sing that. He is Lord. He is Lord. He is risen from the dead. He is Lord. But it's only when our wills have surrendered to the divine will that he truly is Lord.
That's why he says, "When I dissolve her in me and make myself the life of the whole operating of the creature, her heartbeat, her word, her thought, her motion, and her breath are all of God."
And they're all of God living in her. She conceals heaven, and she conceals earth within herself. All heaven and earth inside of you. This is incredible.
And in appearance, one sees a creature. In other words, we are a veil for this great mystery. As Jesus in his incarnation, the flesh veiled the divinity.
People only saw the man, and only a few of them suspected something greater. People look at us. They see nothing.
She conceals heaven and earth within herself. And in appearance, other people see only a creature. A greater grace, a prodigy more pretentious, a sanctity more heroic than my fiat, he said, "I could not give."
This is the Lord saying this is the ultimate, absolute, outermost limit of grace for us. And it's given to us at the worst of times.
Where sin abounds, grace dot even more abound. St. Paul tells us a letter to the Romans. See, the work of creation is great. The work of redemption is even greater.
My fiat, making the creature live in my will, surpasses both one and the other. In fact, in creation my fiat created and put out my works, but did not remain as the center of life in the created things.
In redemption my fiat remained as the center of life in my humanity, but did not remain as the center of life in the rest of the redeemed.
Rather, if their will does not adhere to mine, they render vain the fruits of my redemption. But with my fiat, making the creature live in my will, I remain as the center of life of the creature.
And therefore I repeat to you, as at other times, that my fiat will be the true glory of the work of creation and the fulfillment of the abundant fruits of the work of redemption.
Here is the reason why I want nothing else from you than that my fiat be your life and that you look at nothing other than my will.
Because I want to be the center of your life. I think the only response to that is to say, "Lord, please, I know I'm the last person on the planet that you would even look at to offer such a gift to.
I am the definition of nothingness, and not only that, but unworthy nothingness. And yet because you want this to happen, I ask you to do it.
Yes, work your miracle in me, Lord. Amen.